so today I decided that I would change a
couple of things first of all I wanted
to add some foliage in the middle of the
time to just kind of see how that would
look and I decided to change the colors
of those two buildings next to this one
simply because all the buildings right
now are white walls with blue windows
and I don't think that's a great idea so
I did I decided to change up some colors
which just makes the whole city look
more realistic also less boring and then
there's the fact that I add in another
building I am actually kind of afraid
that I'm doing too many things in silver
city now and I am also afraid that I'll
have to resign what I said about about
quitting this series because like I said
even though I did announce the ending of
the series with every episode that I
make of this it seems like there's going
to be another two coming up and it just
never ends the ride never ends and
that's why I decided to just keep going
with this and see where i can get the
city of course this is all rounding up
the city and actually finishing it but
I'm still going to add a couple more
buildings and it's pretty it's kind of
going to be a long series after all I
think although I might end it a episode
20 or something I know what oh I'm right
now an episode 15 is so I suppose
there'll be a good idea and yeah
basically the idea that I had for this
episode was to just live stream this
once again look at the city and look at
the things which I decided I wanted to
change which is not a way of playing the
game then I would normally recommend but
this is just the kind of this is just
that time when you've nearly finished
something and you just need to round
things up and change a couple of things
and I'd say that in such a case it's a
good idea to start experimenting I mean
there are many ways to play this game
obviously and one of them would be the
perfectionist way where you build things
and as soon as you don't like it you
change it and although that does work
and you do get some nice projects at the
end it is somewhat time consuming and
they're very most it's very much cost me
also I place those Dutch flags because
there was live streaming and I can
contain my Dutch pride but
the thing with that perfectionist
approach is the fact that and I've had
this problem as well is that you start
building how you start removing things
they start perfection ins and it takes
ages and eventually you might drop the
project so I'd say it might be a better
idea to just move on with things even if
you don't like them and then when you're
finishing everything you can come back
to those things and change them to
something that you do like which is
something that i did with these two
buildings because at first I didn't like
them at all and now I realized that the
thing that they missed was colors they
were just white box and nobody likes
those things so I decided to give them
some colors but although of course they
shouldn't be too bright but I think this
was am pretty good solution I like them
now so I don't know this is actually
realistic but overhear people in the
Netherlands just build pink skyscrapers
and stuff like that so I didn't think
that's too much of a problem and at that
point I decided I need to make this
tower higher mainly for the reason that
I talked about in the last episode you
kind of do want that signature
skyscraper to stand out and I know that
I said that I would have two floors to
this but then I built this one floor and
it actually seems like this will do fine
perfectly fine because like I said you
don't want the main tower to be too high
and watch the other towers because that
would be kind of annoying you don't
really want the other towers to look
smaller short simply because you have
this one enormous massive block in the
middle of it and I don't know what other
buildings i'm going to add maybe a
couple more like the thing that i want
to do is I want to add a couple of
buildings on the boulevard next to the
waterfront simply because I do want to
take pictures from that angle because
you know if you have a city you have a
river running through the city you're
going to have to have some nice build a
fire on which you can take pitches and
of course the skyline is pretty nice
from over there and I want to add a
couple of superb ish houses I have no
idea how to tackle those things yet so
i'll have to look at a couple of
pictures and actually judge what I can
do and what I need to do and I might add
some farm lands around this because that
wouldn't be too time consuming but it
would be a very nice way to fill
the general area and that's basically
I'm going to tackle this and I know that
I haven't been making too many let's
play videos as of lately I've kind of
had a city obsession and it's hard to do
anything about this and i know i said
that i make videos whenever i feel like
making certain things and I certainly
don't want to make videos against my own
will and that's why I've been making too
many city videos and if I wasn't making
videos I was either playing simcity 4 or
doing homework which kind of sucks for
various reasons the fact is and I don't
know if you can recognize this but I
think I'd almost rather have tons of
schoolwork to do so that I don't have
any free time than having just that tiny
little bit to do and keep
procrastinating it because what I get
then is then I don't play roller coaster
can 3 because I feel like oh no I have
to do something I have to do and work on
my schoolwork but then eventually I
start procrastinating that as well and
then at the end of the day I haven't
done anything and then I just start up
684 because I'm like him might as well
although that game is really fun and I
think actually some people told me to do
a let's play of that it's not going to
happen I'm definitely not that good at
the game only played for fun and I
really only want to show videos of
things of which I think that I at least
have something to offer which hasn't
been offered before or tutorials in a
way and I haven't gone any of that stuff
for SimCity 4 I mean quite honestly I
kind of suck at the game I like it a lot
and but I'm just terrible at it I'm not
better at simcity 3000 perhaps even 2000
the SimCity 4 just gets too hard with
all different jobs and all that although
I am actually and I've never said this
before but I'm actually considering
making a let's play of city skylines
when that comes out and I know anyone
has heard about this I suppose it's a
good time for an update but like the
roller coaster community is all hyped
for a game such as architects theme box
to do to a lesser extent I don't know
and roller coaster tycoon world the
decent city community which is kind of
similar to what
kuhn community in various ways I mean
it's a very old game one of the most
successful games ever it got a reboot in
2013 which wasn't all that successful
and everybody was mad about it and then
other companies came along and they said
hey we can make rip officers of this
game which you're going to be so much
better and sim city skyline at what
cities skylines is just about that it's
probably a.m. same city ripoff it kind
of is but then again it's a lot better
probably hopefully and that's what the
entire community is hoping now and
judging from some trailers now seen it
does look really awesome and the studio
is behind it or really nice as well so
I'm actually looking forward to that so
I suppose that's something to look
forward to and i was talking about
parker takes a minute ago but i have
noticed that not everybody knows about
this game i think globally key made a
really great video about it I'm multiple
great videos about that so check those
out but basically it's a game which is
very much like roller coaster tycoon and
it's very much like roller coaster kun
one it's not really about the custom
scenery or making realistic parks it's
really just about the gameplay and the
fun but it's got really cute graphics
and the creators have done everything
right which Atari has done wrong I said
I'd say they actually have some great
interaction with the community they
actually do take requests from people
and they implement things which people
have requested and it's really awesome
and they actually do live streams of
them building the game so even if I
don't like the game eventually I'm going
to have to admit that I actually do like
the way that they're sharing how they're
making the game and I wish this was the
future of gaming because honestly we've
been attacked by corporations out for
money with their mobile devices games
and all that and really what the world
needs is some indie developers who
clearly have fun creating the game and
who clearly have fun interacting with
the community and everything just
revolves around the game and just having
fun with it and that's what gaming
should be all about but that was my rent
for today and this is pretty much all of
the footage that I have to show you
today so thank you for watching and see
you next time